c'est vendredi soir
les cours sont terminés au collège notre
dame de foy près de québec
seuls quelques étudiantes en création de
modes de s'activent toujours avec elle
une finissante en photographie du cégep
de matane leonis sinotte bruson c'est
son premier contact avec le monde de la
mode est à 22 ans léonie s'apprête à
vivre une autre première à londres cette
fois et les finalistes au concours
annuel de la world photography
organisation elle a été sélectionnée
parmi les étudiants de plus de 350
écoles de photos à travers le monde
le thème imposé évolutions et
révolutions leoni a choisi de traiter
des selphy les égos portrait on est un
peu devenu tout les journalistes de
notre propre vie
ces faucons témoin de tout ce qu'on fait
qui on est faut qu'on s'exprime
fortement le voit qu'ils sachent que
nous sommes fait rire
pour l'étape ultime les dix finalistes
devaient illustrer la notion
d'appartenance leoni a choisi de
présenter sa vision du québec est un peu
plus ce réaliste mais le propos reste
très sérieux ça c'est les deux solitudes
identité c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement personnel quelqu'un d'autre
aurait fait le travail pires moments sur
le v10 thème peut être différents des
miens pas que ça c'est pour la première
image elle a sélectionné avec beaucoup
de soin chacun petits personnages et à
l'augmenter discuter avec eux avant de
les photographier c'est viviane est là
vient du cameroun qui a émigré avec son
mari puis ses trois enfants
à matane pierre en fait à part sa ligne
de vêtements la fabrique ses vêtements
d'inspiration québécoise et africaines
bien sûr puis je trouvais que ça
représentait tellement bien le mix des
cultures ni c'est une élève qui
travaillent énormément alors beaucoup
d'autonomie donc déjà comme artiste si
vous voulez on voyait que elle sera en
mesure de répondre à la deuxième étape
donc ça prend une étudiant qui est
déterminé qu'il ya beaucoup de
créativité
le collège de matane située à 7 heures
de route de montréal a acquis une
réputation internationale grâce entre
autres à son programme de photos mais
c'est une très bonne série au travail
léonie et la deuxième photographe de ce
collège a participé au concours et c'est
un élève d'ici qui a remporté le grand
prix étudiant l'an dernier
le volet international est d'une
importance capitale pour le collège de
ma tante si on n'avait pas ce volet là
je pense que on aurait de la difficulté
à survivre
chez nous particulièrement en photo on
est à 70 % d'étudiants français qui
viennent de france le ou la vainqueur du
grand prix remporté 45 mille dollars de
matériel photo pour son école il obtient
du même coup une carte de visite
exceptionnelle pour sa future carrière
suis très excité puis surtout de
rencontrer
il va avoir des artistes photographes
des gens qui ont des grandes carrières
rencontrer ces personnes là ça va être
super intéressant j'ai aussi rencontré
c'est quoi la réalité d'un étudiant à
l'autre bout de la planète ça ça va être
vraiment riche simple
mon rêve ce serait de vivre la
photographie peu importe la méthode pour
financer des projets qui me ressemble et
projets que peut-être un jour
j'exposerai mais l'important c'est
vraiment de pouvoir lui faire quitter la
chute est au vélo
[Musique]